morning to you a report from the police
watchdog has said that preventing
violence against women and girls should
be given the same priority as countering
terrorism
official statistics show there are 1.6
million female victims of domestic abuse
in england and wales but three quarters
of cases are closed early without
charges ever being brought and the
watchdog identified what it called a
staggering variation between different
police forces in how crimes like
domestic abuse are treated
the report was commissioned by the home
secretary pretty patel after the murder
of sarah everard by a metropolitan
police officer earlier this year
jemima walker reports
after the murder of sarah everard the
message from women was clear streets are
lost and we deserve to be safe on the
streets in the wake of the marketing
executive's death the home secretary
ordered a major report
published today that report demands a
radical shift in policing
stopping violence against women it says
should be as much of a priority as
fighting terrorism one woman every three
days is killed by a man there's 1.6
million victims of domestic abuse and
there are crimes like stalking and
voyeurism
and online abuse
where 8 out of 10 victims
are women or girls and the position
really is quite staggering and the
police alone cannot solve this problem
but there are areas where according to
the report police can and must improve
it says there are major gaps in data
collection which does not allow for
proper oversight or accountability
the use of the domestic violence
disclosure scheme where there are fears
about someone's past convictions
requires immediate improvement
and there are extreme concerns that
around three quarters of reported
domestic abuse cases are closed early
without the suspect being charged
erica says she was abused and now
campaigns to get more police support for
victims
with my experience i felt like my case
was just dismissed pushed out the way so
that
they could essentially just keep going
i don't believe it's something they do
intentionally they're not malicious but
they do what they can which is they work
with what they have so essentially it
comes down to the government to be able
to support the police met police etc
anywhere around the country to reassure
people that they are safe if they have
something they want to report they will
be listened to and supported the police
watchdog points to an epidemic of
violence against women and girls
for campaigners it's a warning which
should have been issued long ago
i think the report focuses a lot on
women as victims and it is right that
there needs to be better support for
women as victims
but it doesn't talk enough about
prevention
and how to tackle men as perpetrators
and how to spot some of those early
signs of misogyny and tackle them
head-on and early on before the the
worst case scenario happens the report
says the whole system policing health
and education
must take a fundamentally new approach
for the women who still walk with keys
between their fingers it's been a long
time coming jeremiah walker sky news
well the environment secretary george
eustis is here it's good to see you this
morning look this report was
commissioned by the home secretary does
that mean the government is going to act
on the recommendations
well obviously pretty patera will now
look at uh these recommendations but i
think you know this report does
highlight uh some differences between
police forces and i think in these sorts
of situations violence against women is
a serious problem domestic violence has
also been a problem for some time now
and what we really need to do is to
learn from those police forces that are
addressing this well and i think report
highlights that some of them are doing
far better than others and that actually
try and replicate those approaches that
uh that work in parts of the country
it's it it's not purely a police issue
though is it i mean this report says
three quarters of domestic abuse cases
are closed without even a suspect being
charged and not all but some of that is
down to to victims sort of withdrawing
the complaint if you like i mean there's
a wider societal issue here isn't there
yes well it is and i know in devon and
cornwall uh that the police force where
i come from we have some real problems
with uh domestic violence in some of our
communities and actually often uh some
of the things that can work quite well
are
um you know involvement to to help the
partners that get angry and get violent
and actually to try and and help you
know defuse and manage some of those
stressful situations in the home which
often are behind some of these things so
you get you know you can get those uh
those other sorts of interventions that
can help deal um with problems of
domestic violence i mean i know there
there is already a scheme in place to
help sort of
children primary school children learn
about healthy relationships but if if
children are being brought up in a home
where there is
violence or aggression
can that can they be targeted in a way
to to make sure they don't get caught in
that spiral
well you know we have lots of family
support workers and and interventions
and obviously social services and local
authorities it's not just those that are
under a very close watch they also have
family support workers that try to do
this but you know a chaotic home
environment where there's um lots of
anger lots of violence it isn't a great
environment for those children and there
are some good programs that i've seen
where you get interventions to try to
defuse those types of situations um and
get both parents in that relationship to
you know to learn to sort of manage
their anger issues and that can actually
deal with some of the sort of lower
level
domestic violence of course you then get
still those very serious cases and
that's when the police do have to drive
it through and take a prosecution
forward yeah i mean in terms of what the
government can do to signal its intent
what about the istanbul convention i
mean that was an international agreement
to to to come to
to sort of common standards in how we
deal with violence against women and
girls it was open for signatures in 2011
10 years ago 45 countries have signed
the uk still hasn't i mean do we need to
do that well look i think the fact that
priti patel um you know commissioned uh
this report asked for this piece of work
shows the seriousness with which she
takes this issue
and i think what we really want is that
uh you know domestic policy response to
deal with this problem learn from those
police forces that are addressing uh the
problem and doing well
and replicate that in the others and i'm
sure that's exactly what pretty patel
will want to be doing with police forces
around the country okay look we're going
to have a lot more on that throughout
the course of the morning but in the
meantime can we talk about
covid and travel as someone who's
finally going on a holiday next month
this is particularly interest to me i
have to say what is happening are we
expecting an announcement on these sort
of pcr tests as you return to the uk is
that going to be happening today well my
understanding is no decisions have
actually been taken yet although i
understand there may be a meeting today
to review this we regularly
review those travel restrictions
obviously we took
a very important step a bit earlier this
summer when we
removed the need to quarantine for those
coming from ambulance countries that was
a really big step forward but we have
retained um the need for testing and
that's really so that we can pick up any
variants of concern through that pcr
test but look i know um that this has
been raised by the travel industry that
they think some of that testing may be
unnecessary may be onerous the
government will be uh listening to that
and obviously the uh the coveted
subcommittee of cabinet that uh decides
these things will be considering that
probably later today i mean there seems
to be a pretty clear indication and i
don't quite know where it all comes from
but
lots of rumors flying about that pcrs
could be scrapped for lateral tests
which obviously are cheaper and easier
is that something you've heard
well um i haven't heard because i'm not
on that particular subcommittee that
deals with this and obviously you know
they will want to consider all of the
evidence before taking a final decision
i mean the rationale for the pcr test is
that you can do sort of genome
sequencing of variants and you can
therefore detect possible variants of
concern and the
the difficulty with the lateral flow
test although it's cheaper and it's
simpler to do is is that it's not able
to pick up those variants so that's the
rationale and been the rationale so far
for making sure that we keep some of
that pcr testing in place but when you
look at the situation that our our code
infection rates are higher than they are
in a lot of mainland europe particularly
even though our vaccination system is is
is pretty good um
but with that in mind i mean it it does
raise questions doesn't mean even the
health secretary made the point that he
thought this this need to be needed to
be seriously looked at
uh yes so sergeant did say that we would
um you know look at this he doesn't want
to have unnecessary testing in place but
i think he also recognizes the value of
those pcr tests so you know there's a
there's a discussion to be had about
this as i said we've already made that
big step forward of ending the need for
quarantine from people returning from
ambulance countries that was a game
changer
if we can do
further refinements on testing then
obviously we'll look at that to you know
reduce those burdens but we do
also need to be you know mindful and
vigilant against new variants coming in
we have done incredibly well with our
vaccination program it enabled us to
open things up again and the the
vaccination that we've done is
preventing those hospitalizations and
keeping that mortality right down
but we what we don't want is to end up
with a variant that can evade the
vaccine and that's what we've got to
remain vigilant about it it is reaching
a critical point though for the travel
industry isn't it obviously it's been a
dreadful couple of years and we're now
easing off into a sort of quieter season
so
if there was ever a right time to do
this it's now isn't it well look it's
been a very very uh difficult time for
the travel industry we absolutely
recognize that that's why we've done all
we can to
you know have those easements in place
reduce the restrictions as quickly as we
can but you know arguably the biggest
threat to the travel industry is that we
do get another variant that manages to
get around the vaccine that the vaccine
can't deal with then we're into another
full lockdown and that's not what we
want that's why we've taken this
cautiously step by step because we want
each step we take to be irreversible i
know you're making us wait for any
announcement and that's fair enough to
to an extent but there is also talk of
scrapping the amber and just having red
and green now
that may seem sensible to a lot of
people the problem is that's following
on from what the labour party was
demanding
months ago
well i i actually still think there's
the rationale
for amber and has been because we have
gained by having those pcr tests on
people returning because it has given us
uh extra protection extra surveillance
against those potential variants of
concern the redless countries remain uh
the highest risks but uh but we think
there's been that uh rationale for the
ambulance and by the way i'm not waiting
for the announcement i'm waiting for a
decision that i understand has not yet
been discussed and perhaps will be later
today okay um can we talk reshuffle
because obviously you've kept your job
uh which is very good news to you and
you've got the first meeting of the new
cabinet what about nine o'clock this
morning something like that yes um
what has the prime minister been trying
to achieve with this reshuffle because
he i mean he certainly hasn't created a
cabinet with a a sort of single ideology
has he
uh no but i i think you know the
conservative party has always been a
broad church and any government any
prime minister will want to bring
together a cabinet of all the talents
and we'll want to make sure you've got
lots of different perspectives
represented that's how you get a good
debate in cabinet and that's exactly
what he's done and i think really what
he's uh seeking to do with this
reshuffle is get the team in place that
he wants to you know deliver a post
pandemic the recovery of our country to
to build back better build back greener
get our economy going again uh get wages
up get people in better paid jobs uh
improve skills and this is his big focus
over the uh remaining part of this
parliament and he's assembled his team
to do that so i mean very much want to
focus on our domestic agenda and
and within that then how big a role is
michael gove going to play housing
secretary
and yet the the sort of leveling up
agenda seems to fall within his remit
now that's
going to be crucial moving forward for
the conservatives isn't it yes well i
worked very closely with michael gove
when he was in my own department in in
defra when i was a minister there
he's got a formidable intellect very
good at problem solving very good at
getting to
grip with detail quickly
there are some very important reforms
we've got on planning where we want to
simplify the process but make sure we've
got the right uh protections in place
make sure we build aesthetically you
know beautiful housing around the
country and not the usual sort of
identicate things that we've become used
to so i think he's in a gonna be a very
good position to take those reforms
forward and also he retains that brief
around uh you know the wider uk and
that's a passion of his but is it right
that at this point in in a government
cycle that we are i mean it seems pretty
clear you're gearing up for the next
election that could be 2023 it could be
2024.
oliver dowden seems to be pretty
convinced that now you need to get on
the election footing is that your
understanding well look um i think what
oliver darden said is we should be ready
for an election whenever it might come
um and um that's what every party
chairman will always do their task is to
make sure that the party is ready but
for cabinet as a whole uh our priority
is to deliver we've still got uh several
years left of this parliament
and we've got a lot that we want to
achieve there's going to be a lot of
challenges that need addressing uh post
this pandemic that's going to be our
absolute focus and can you do that
within even if you've got sort of two or
three years left can you deliver
everything that was promised back in
well look the um you know the pandemic
wasn't in anyone's manifesto as the
prime minister said so we've already had
to take difficult but necessary and
right choices on things like the the
health and social care levy that we've
introduced to to deal with that huge
backlog in the nhs and also to get our
social care system on a
firmer more viable footing so we're
willing to take those uh difficult
decisions but yeah we also want to crack
on and deliver many of those things that
were in our manifesto um delivering for
the environment which is a very much a
focus for me with an environment bill
going through now improving our approach
on things like animal welfare so i've
got uh bills like that that i'm focusing
on other departments will have their own
priorities that will also manifest their
commitments okay and it's so good to
talk to you thank you thank you very
much
well still to come on the program this
morning in the wake of the violence
against women report calling for
fundamental change we'll speak to
labour's shadow policing minister sarah
jones at five past eight
and the twenty past eight will talk to
the managing director of tui ahead of
the government's international travel
announcement expected later on today
and the champion returns emma radekano
is back home after her victory at the
u.s open jackie beltran is going to be
talking to her later in the program and
you can catch that full interview at
about half past nine
now an american judge has accused prince
andrew of playing a game of hide and
seek behind palace walls over a lawsuit
seeking damages against him for sexual
assault
virginia guthrie is pursuing legal
actions over allegations that she was
forced to have sex with him when she was
meanwhile a separate court in manhattan
has ruled that prince andrew can unseal
a settlement agreement reese which
reached between miss guffrey and
convicted sex offender jeffrey epstein
in 2009.
the prince's lawyers say the agreement
prevents her from pursuing legal action
against him prince andrew denies all the
allegations and says the abuse never
happened
two men had been charged with a murder
of 29 year old journalist lira mckee who
was shot dead in derry
in 2019 well let's get the latest from
shingi marurika who's in the newsroom um
who are these men shingi
morning stephen so these two men will
appear later this morning via video link
at derry magistrates court charged with
the murder of lira mckee and police
northern ireland have put a statement
detailing a bit more on who they are in
that statement they say this
detectives from the police service of
northern ireland's major investigation
team have charged two men with the
murder of 29 year old journalist lira
mckee who was shot dead by terrorists in
derry on april on april 18 2019 the pair
aged 21 and 33 have also been charged
with possession of a firearm and
ammunition with intent to endanger life
riot possession of petrol bombs throwing
petrol bombs and arson the 33 year old
has also been charged with robbery a
third man aged 20 will also appear in
court today he's been charged with riot
possession of petrol bombs and throwing
petrol bombs and then on top of this we
have another 19 year old man who was
also arrested during the same operation
who has been released while we wait on a
report to northern ireland's public
prosecution service so like i said today
free men will appear in court
in connection with this case and we know
that two of those men have been charged
with murder
thank you
well let's have a look at some of the
other headlines for you this morning and
new research suggests long covered
symptoms rarely persist beyond 12 weeks
in children unlike adults the review
published in the pediatric infectious
disease journal suggests that long
covered in children and adolescents is
less common than previously feared
a five-year-old has won a legal case
against the environment agency over
gases from a landfill site that his mum
said risks shortening his life their
lawyers argued there was a public health
emergency around wally's quarry near
newcastle under lyme in staffordshire a
doctor told a hearing that matthew
richard's recovery from chronic lung
disease was being hit by emissions from
the site
it's absolutely amazing matthew has i
mean he's not just
fought for his own fresh air he's fought
for a whole community
with thousands and thousands of people
who are suffering
you know it you know the the complaints
are coming in
from
sometimes they've been coming up from 10
miles away from the quarry
so he's fought for
thousands
the home secretary priddy patel has
criticized climate change protesters for
halting traffic on the m25 describing
them as selfish protesters from the
insulate britain group stopped thousands
of motorists at four different junctions
shortly after eight in the morning on
wednesday for the second time in three
days
there's a new name at the top of the
sunday times university league table st
andrews has claimed first place with
oxford and cambridge knocked off the top
spots for the first time ever
the inventor and entrepreneur sir clive
sinclair has died at the age of 81. he
helped develop the pocket calculator and
crucially brought home computers to
british high street stores at relatively
affordable prices
but perhaps he was less known for his
less successful invention the sinclair
c5 it's an iconic design though who was
given a knighthood in 1983.
now analysis by the sky news data team
has shown the number of people who
outstay their visas and remain in the uk
without permission each year is
significantly higher than the numbers of
migrants crossing the english channel in
small boats
between 2018 and 2020 an average of 11
400 people smuggled themselves into
britain each year by boat
six times that number more than sixty
six thousand remain in the uk illegally
having overstayed their visas
an annual average of five five thousand
two hundred stay after being refused
asylum and a similar number come in on
false documents
the figures are an estimate since
official data is incomplete
lisa holland reports
well i'm stuck
so i can't go forward it's like you
don't exist
no
feel very sad
yeah very thought
moomin came to the uk as a teenage boy
12 years ago but has missed out entirely
on the rights of passage into adulthood
lost in the uk's asylum system my life
is too hard
especially i don't have any paperwork
so anyway when i go to like for the job
all these things
they need paperwork and these things
so i don't have that
moomin on the left of frame says this
picture was taken with his brothers in
afghanistan shortly before he departed
aged 14 after refusing to join the
taliban he arrived on the back of a
lorry
his lawyer says half of his time here
has been as an illegal immigrant though
he's lodged another appeal
there's a lack of data but the latest
research estimates around a million
people in total are in the uk illegally
and the overwhelming majority like
moomin did not arrive by small boat
what would you like your life to be like
i want to be like a
good businessman
yeah in future
so
and
could my own like house
own business
i don't have any money one pound like
i buy like chicken chips for myself
the state doesn't want moomin but his
afghan community does staying with
friends and helping in a butcher's where
they say they give him food and pocket
money the only way he can survive
he says he's had spells in college and
for a few years was allowed to work
others in the shop say they feel sorry
for moomin because he's trapped in a
life that's so unfulfilled he came to me
he said please help me and
that time i help him
yeah
but not all the time i can't help him
because i have my own family as well he
tries to be happy but he can't because
you know without
document he don't have so it's very hard
not easy
so he's sad all the time
we didn't provide the home office with
moomin's details so they were unable to
address his case specifically but a
spokesperson said the government is
committed to ensuring asylum claims are
considered without unnecessary delays
and its new plan for immigration seeks
to welcome those who come through safe
and legal routes lisa holland sky news
china has warned the new defence
cooperation pact between the uk the
united states and australia risks the
major new defense alliance announced
between the uk the united states and
australia
excuse me it's been sending ripples
around the world with no shortage of
strong words issued by global powers
outside the arrangement china said the
move risks catalyzing a nuclear arms
race the french foreign minister
described it as a stab in the back and
totally incomprehensible
the italian government has approved some
of the strictest anti-covet measures in
the world making it compulsory for all
workers either to show proof of
vaccination a negative test or recent
recovery from infection any worker who
fails to present a valid health
certificate will be suspended without
pay and will be fined but can't be
sacked the new rules come into force
from october the 15th
a lawyer who represented hillary
clinton's 2016 presidential bid has been
charged with lying to the fbi
michael sussman a former federal
prosecutor with ties to the democratic
national committee was indicted for
giving false statements to the fbi in a
meeting two months before the 2016
election
more than 10 000 migrants have set up a
makeshift camp under a bridge connecting
mexico and texas in the latest u.s
border emergency the migrants most of
whom are from haiti have made the
journey across the rio grande with
little food and water and in
temperatures approaching 40 degrees
celsius
this is sky news let's have a look at
the weather for you today
it's going to be wet at times in the
west but elsewhere mostly fine with some
warm sunny spells much of england wales
and eastern scotland will be dry first
thing patches of low cloud or fog
perhaps going to be cloudier further
west with outbreaks of rain and some
brisk winds
rain heavy at times will slowly push
eastwards across ireland northern
ireland and scotland into cornwall and
pembrokeshire as well the rest of
britain mostly dry with some warm sunny
spells meanwhile brighter skies and a
few scattered showers will follow to
western ireland
well still to come for you this morning
where do we go next in protecting women
and girls from violence we'll speak to
her majesty's inspector of constabulary
in a couple of minutes
[Music]
so
now the uk's international travel rules
are expected to be changed later with
reports that pcr tests for double-jabbed
holidaymakers coming back to the uk
could be scrapped now a few minutes ago
the environment secretary george eustis
told me that ministers will discuss the
issue later on today
well my understanding is no decisions
have actually been taken yet although i
understand there may be a meeting today
to review this we regularly
review those travel restrictions
obviously we took
a very important step a bit earlier this
summer when we
removed the need to quarantine for those
coming from ambulance countries that was
a really big step forward but we have
retained the need for testing and that's
really so that we can pick up any
variants of concern through that pcr
test
ali faltersku is here now he didn't give
a lot away i mean he claimed he didn't
actually know what any decision was
going to be but what are the options
well i think what people are expecting
is a simplification of what has been
there until now of course since june
we've had quarantine since february
we've had some hotel quarantine as well
lots of testing requirements and there
has been speculation that what we will
see is effectively fewer tests needed
for people who are vaccinated so people
won't necessarily need a pcr test if
they come back they could take a lateral
flow test instead on day two they might
not even need a lateral flow test before
boarding the flight to the uk so there
has been speculation that we would see a
simplification of the testing
requirements and that we could see the
ambulance scrapped all together so
instead there would be as fewer
countries on the red list and they would
be really no go and then a green list
which would be go you can go on holiday
to those places but i think what we
heard from george used to say was a
pretty cautious tone actually he was
talking about the importance of pcr
tests for spotting new variants uh he
said there's still a rationale for at
the ambulance so i was quite surprised
really by how cautious his tone was if
we are indeed going to see our
speculation suggest the ambulance
scrapped this afternoon he did they
confirm that the subcommittee will be
meeting that no decision has been taken
yet so i think watch her space talking
about people meeting it's the new
cabinet meeting this morning isn't it
that's right very exciting the
excitement is palpable here in
westminster the brand new cabinet of
course uh to remind you of some of the
big changes got less trust moving to
foreign secretary now two before those
great officers of state uh will be women
uh she is the first conservative female
foreign secretary replacing dominic rob
who of course of course goes to the
ministry of justice in a bit of a
demotion we've got uh michael gove
moving to housing nadim zahawi going to
education so lots of changes a couple
more announcements for junior ministers
expected today but yeah lots of
excitement that very first cabinet
meeting and lots on the agenda real
shift towards the domestic policy we
expect okay alex thank you
now back to our top story this morning
and that is that report from the police
watchdog which says tackling violence
against women and girls is as important
as counter-terrorism it was commissioned
by the home secretary in the wake of the
murder of sarah everards and it found
there were problems
uh unevenness and inconsistencies in
police handling of misogynistic violence
well let's talk to her majesty's
inspector of constabulary
zoe billingham and it's good to see you
this morning look what what are the key
points here
so we face an epidemic of violence
against women and girls and this report
lays this out in really the starkest
terms 1.6 million
female victims of domestic abuse
one woman is killed every three days
by a man and half the women that we
surveyed are fearful to walk out in
their own neighborhoods so
what we're saying is rather than ask the
police to do more of more of the same
more training uh better supervision
we're saying that there needs to be a
bold and radical approach to tackling
violence against women and girls there
needs to be a whole new system
brought into place focusing on
prevention looking at better funding
making sure that we ruthlessly track
down perpetrators all the sorts of
things that we see in high harm crimes
like terrorism and county lines and
serious and organized crimes that very
same approach we say needs to be applied
in stopping harm happening to women and
girls up and down this country
so how do we apply that then and indeed
you talk of prevention and obviously
that is the best way forward but i mean
that that's a society-wide issue isn't
it not not just a police issue
absolutely and you're spot on and that's
really what we've said in this report um
the police alone cannot solve this
problem there needs to be a change in
tact and a whole system approach so
partners from local authorities through
to probation services and the courts the
health services schools and education
all need to be mandated by government to
work together in partnership to prevent
crime happening from uh in the first
place but also to identify very clear
strategies as to how they're going to
work together to get after the
perpetrators to actually stop them
offending time and time again we found
some perpetrators that were
harming at least eight or nine victims
at any one time
you know this is a really broad
widespread deep ingrained deep rooted
problem within society but i'm really
optimistic
and i have to be because there is no
alternative that actually working
together there can be a change
you've said it's as important as
countering terrorism which
you know
puts it into some sort of context you
like it as to where it should be on our
priority list but
the problem has to be surely that i mean
terrorism has an ideology i mean it's
it's it's a warped and perverted
ideology but it is there nonetheless
when it comes to this sort of domestic
violence that there isn't an ideology is
there and we don't quite understand why
it happens in the first place
yeah no you're quite right and it takes
very very different forms violence
against women and girls could be
stalking it could be voyeurism it could
be harm created on online it's it's so
broad and it's so deep and of course
what we're not saying is that the crimes
are similar to the crimes of terrorism
but the approach that the police and
agencies take to tackling terrorism is
what we want to see in tackling violence
against women and girls so there's a
very clear national strategy police
forces know exactly what they need to do
other partners are required to cooperate
to prevent terrorism happening there's
proper funding and there's a real
clarity of focus and mission and that's
exactly what we say needs to happen in
terms of
the the the attack if you like the the
the collective public agencies need to
bring to bear on stopping violence
against women and girls happening and we
don't choose
words like epidemic lightly but we have
seen through this work the volume the
breadth the depth and the harm that is
being caused by women
two women every single day
by men and that needs to stop
how
do you go about with all of these
different measures empowering women
because that's surely got to be really
important here when you look at the
figures in your report saying three
quarters of cases are closed without a
charge being brought in not all cases
but in some of those cases that's down
to the victims sort of with withdrawing
their complaint how do you empower women
through all of this to make sure that
they do stand their ground they are
supported enough to follow through on a
case
yeah there's lots of things that need to
change in that and of course some women
are very clear that they don't want a
criminal justice outcome and that's
absolutely right for them but they do
want the harm to stop but other women
are being discouraged quite early on in
the process if they've been the victim
of a serious crime um they're being sort
of it's being suggested it's going to
take a very long time to get to court
that they may have to hand over their
mobile phone what we want to see is the
police going in with an attitude that
we're the police we've got certain tools
we've got certain powers that we are
going to apply as best we possibly can a
to keep you safe before we bring the
perpetrator to justice but also to
support you to gather the evidence
to make sure that we build the case to
not push it back onto women to make
decisions but to take the case forward
so that perpetrators are brought to
justice and we know from our research
that if one perpetrator is brought to
justice and and hopefully receives a
sufficiently stiff sentence
within the courts and that's one
perpetrator taken off the streets who's
then not able to harm not only the
victim survivor but also other women
because there is often a real pattern of
offending we see in perpetrators that
prey on vulnerable women in particular
sorry billingham it's good to talk to
you this morning thank you
thank you
okay time to have a look at the sport
for this morning with david
ah record breakers me too
world's slowest dog
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by the vitality running world cup
welcome home yes
yes
lovely place i'm surprised you've not
got the yorkshire accent you've been
here that long i've been here like
what's it 11 years now yeah 11 12 years
um what's it up dog
[Laughter]
right in all these years i've been here
all i've been to i'd say is like nando's
meadow hall
tesco
sheffield is like probably the casino
yeah but sheffield is like a big village
everybody everybody knows everybody when
you're out i know yeah see what i mean
so that's when i go out and as well says
everyone knows you're out everyone says
they used to see you at nando's but no
one sees you anymore i just think that
the
pressure yeah you know the pressure's
gone up so i just kind of reserved
myself a bit more and
training training pressure's increasing
they expect a lot more from me so i've
got to kind of rest my body more that's
why i don't go out as much do you uh
did you miss rob at the first part of
this training yeah definitely yeah it
made a massive difference yeah yeah
definitely definitely having it rob is
he's a gafferini do you know i mean
having the gaffer there are not there is
like you feel the presence um but in a
way right it worked out well because
we've got a good team
and i always look at like old school
training where
like let's say freddie roach had manny
pacquiao's assistant trainers with him
teddy atlas kevin rooney
customato
different something certain athletes
tend to move to different trainers but
what we done we kept it all in house
and we was able to still perform and
train even when one person's away we're
still able to construct a good training
camp even though there's one system
a coach has to say i'm training these
guys with one system but you also have
to understand individually what makes
johnny tick and what makes ajt so mine
might be i might need motivation i might
need that motivating like come on chad
you're great you're doing this
you might need
more work you know what we're going to
do 20 rounds you want to fit this guy
going that's why we're working 20 rounds
and that's your motivation i might not
need to do that i might need to do 10
rounds but i just need to be told i can
do it and like once you kind of find
what makes an athlete tick
then they will buy into your system and
then once they bought into your system
you're more than likely going to go and
have a champion when you're saying that
i see the respect you have for rob
cause you've gotta wanna fight for rob
i've gotta wanna i've gotta wanna fight
and die for rob so when i'm going out on
the battlefield i don't wanna go into a
fight and it's like i don't really get
along with my coach i don't really
believe in his system too much
um because this is me everyone's
different the other fight retrains might
believe in it wholeheartedly so i want
to
fight for this guy you give your heart
and soul for him yeah you've got money
yeah how's it how
we'll talk about usyk how's it how's the
mental approach going towards fighting
the southpaw of all six
caliber of what he's done as a an
amateur and as a cruiserweight what's
what's the mindset there
so what he's done is a cruiserweight um
archie moore come up from light heavy to
heavy weight for some of the great
fighters all boxers can move up weight
some fighters kind of say oh i feel
better at the bigger weight i carry more
power i feel fresher i mean he's not
having to make weight so i've kind of in
my mind i've removed the way
the the conversation about
this is the heavyweight and he's a
cruiserweight
i get that
but i like to challenge myself so i said
let's remove that out of the way and
let's look at where i am at skill wise
technical wise
because i've got what i already have
anyway the strength i've got since i
come in boxing in 2008 i kind of had a
rapid rise and that's maybe due to the
fact of sheer strength mental strength
and heart she has size and heart taken
on massive challenges early on
[Music]
morning
i'll join later
david thank you still to come for you
this morning elections in russia start
today it's a three-day process we'll
talk to the executive director of the
anti-corruption foundation in a couple
of minutes
[Music]
i lost my father in november 2015. it
was a very sudden death um he was a
politician he was in the public eye so
there was a bit of a me just storm
afterwards and there was a lot of
problems for me too uh sort out
including insolvency and i think that at
the age of 25 i just wasn't really
capable to i didn't really understand
how to deal with a complex probate
estate um and this sort of site you know
this cycle carried on and as it got
worse i started to develop this terrible
binge eating disorder and i sort of you
know looked to food as a way of coping
with my my you know emotions and over
the period the next next two or three
years i've spiraled from you know about
10 and a half stone to over 17 stone and
just couldn't control it really
i think it was um you know there was a
lot of indicators along the way
including my father's inquest where
because he had a terrible eating
disorder as well and he was obese
that wasn't enough to shock me when the
pathologist said you know your father
had hypertension and high cholesterol
there was a number of things you know
people passing me on the tube and
thinking i was pregnant that wasn't
enough looking at myself in my
reflection and realizing that i couldn't
fit into anything that wasn't enough
finally the triggering point for me was
when i caught coronavirus and i was
lying in the hospital bed um i have an
underlying condition i have rheumatoid
arthritis which was of course impacted
by my um my weight gain and my binge
eating and you know medical staff at the
hospital i was treated at were tired um
they were seeing very very unwell people
throughout the first period you know the
first stage of lockdown and i think they
were tired and they just turned around
to me and said you know you wouldn't be
so unwell had you looked after yourself
and you've really got to take your uh
health and make it a priority i never
thought that i would be competing on
stage with all these wonderful ladies
from all different backgrounds but i
think the main thing for me is that it's
given me a voice and a platform you know
miss great britain is a tremendous
vehicle for change and i am incredibly
passionate about reframing eating
disorders as the rightful mental health
conditions they are um and repositioning
them as a public health concern and also
drawing attention to the fact that
sometimes complicated grief can really
you know lead to somebody spiraling out
of control but you know you can recover
i am you know an example of that and i
want other people to know that you know
recovery is possible whatever's happened
to you and you know if you seek early
intervention whether it may be
depression or an eating disorder there
is help for you
[Music]
so
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
a band of rain and brisk winds in the
west will very slowly move eastwards
today much of scotland and northern
ireland will be cloudy with outbreaks of
rain heavy at times england and wales
will be largely dry with warm sunny
spells ireland will brighten up later
from the west
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high air pollution levels remain
low on friday as breezier and wetter
conditions move in from the west
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now voting has begun in russia's
parliamentary elections many of
president putin's most vocal critics
have been barred from running amid a
crackdown on dissidents and the outcome
is regarded as a foregone conclusion
well let's talk to executive director of
the anti-corruption foundation and kia
ally of alexi navalny vladimir ashurkov
good to see you this morning i mean is
there any hope whatsoever of this being
a free and fair election
this election wasn't fair and free from
the beginning when it started it was
impossible for independent candidates to
get on the ballot the independent media
over the last six months most of them
have been branded foreign agents and
really had difficulty to operate
so um
the elections have been extended from
one day to three days which makes it
difficult to do election monitoring so
and we expect also that there will be
ballot staffing uh so it's uh uh very
far from fair and uh free election
we do know that president putin's united
russia party of clearly favorites to win
but but the the ratings are
are pretty low what does that tell us
well the standards of living in russia
have been deteriorating for the last
decade
people are becoming more and more
disillusioned with the putin's regime
and this will be reflected in the polls
i mean that where are you on this
electronic voting system that i mean i
know this is a three-day process
um of which only the last days sort of
people voting in person but it's a is
there any chance with this new system
that that could provide a a fairer
outcome
the authorities are
[Music]
introduced this electronic system uh
last year and
it allows to vote electronically in
several regions of russia um we expect
that this electronic voting system will
be used to for ballot staffing and to
falsify the results of the election so
we of course don't support it
so what happens
after this election result if this goes
as you expect and
and
the united russia party wins and you
believe it is not a free and fair result
what happens next
uh we advocate a system of tactical
voting where people vote
in a consolidated manner for a candidate
that's not a candidate of party of power
but has the best chances to win we
believe that this tactic will uh will
enable
uh for maybe 50 candidates maybe 10 of
the parliament uh to be elected and we
there will be independent voices in the
parliament something that was lacking
for the last 10 years
and what difference will that make to to
how president putin continues
the elections are always a
point of stress for authoritarian
governments like russia and uh we
believe that this uh is also a point of
stress for putin
the frenzy with which the authorities
have been banning independent candidates
have been banning uh applications that
allow people to consolidate their vote
shows that uh they really are afraid of
people's uh of uh expression uh of
people's will in this election
i mean
what do you think the international
community should be doing when we were
sort of stood by and watching at the
moment and there's a lot of
international criticism of russia but
could more be done
i think it's important to understand
that russia is
important that what happens in russia is
important for everybody
russia is really uh
assertive and it meddles in elections in
other countries it conducts political
assassinations including britain so
russia
and what to do with it has to be high on
the agenda in all western democracies
okay vladimir good to talk to you thank
you
this is sky news let's have a look at
the weather for you
now it's going to be wet at times in the
west today but elsewhere mostly fine
with some warm sunny spells much of
england wales and eastern scotland will
have a dry start patches of low cloud or
fog
it's going to be cloudier further west
with outbreaks of rain and some brisk
winds see those temperatures so 13 to 16
although about
rain heavy at times will push
pretty slowly eastwards across ireland
northern ireland and scotland into
cornwall and pembrokeshire
the rest of britain will be mostly dry
with some warm sunny spells meanwhile
brighter skies and a few scattered
showers will follow to western ireland
now during the afternoon skies are going
to brighten across ireland and northern
ireland however there will be some rain
that should affect western fringes of
britain heaviest over parts of scotland
as you can see i mean particularly
in the west of scotland the rain band
will stall it should weaken overnight
leaving a zone of thicker cloud and
patchy rain stretching from eastern
scotland to south west england either
side of that mostly dry with some clear
spells and fog patches
also with us here on sky news still to
come for you this morning violence
against women is an epidemic that's the
findings of a new report following the
death of sarah eberhard
and a decision
is
expected on whether or not to scrap pcr
travel tests when you head into the uk
[Music]
one it was my vision to come and protect
regulation future
[Music]
animals like lion can enter into bomas
they kill their livestocks and this
leads to human wildlife
[Music]
so
you